you
[Music]
so it is my great pleasure to introduce
Michael Bruno who is a professor at the
University of Toronto and the director
of the Center for computational medicine
at the university of six children in
Ontario and he is very much interested
in the intersection between machine
learning and medicine working on
computational methods that will allow us
to provide healthcare much more easily
than we are doing right now thank you
and it's really a pleasure to be
visiting you guys at Microsoft where
you're doing some of the cutting-edge
work that's feeding into the things
we're doing and so as we're slow said
I'm really interested in how to improve
the the clinical workflow and the
doctor/patient interaction process with
smart medical devices and you know even
for those of you who are not sort of in
the medical side of things you probably
know about the pain of medical data and
medical records and this is should
update the year on the slide but this is
sort of what the medical data looks like
today you know doctors claim to be
collecting lots and lots and lots of
data but in reality that data is sitting
with what I think of it like as a broom
closet it's if you know exactly what you
put there when you put it there and what
you're you know and do how to find it
you can go and grab the right Kamil
record but if you sort of like I kind of
look looking for something like this the
data is very hard to mine and very hard
to to work with and the electronic
health record systems which are these
broom closets there's been a lot of work
recently talking about this including
and even the popular press so you know
New York Times Magazine had how tech can
turn doctors and do clerical workers
talking about the pain of recording data
into the EHR systems or great article in
England Journal of Medicine called
getting rid of stupid stuff which talked
about how many things in the modern EHR
system are really unnecessary and how
you know entering data into it is a huge
huge pain
and about close to a year ago now in The
New Yorker if you have not this is a
really phenomenal article why doctors
hate their computers talking about all
of the human factors issues that go into
making the doctor experience with their
computer so horrible so you know you
guys are all at the tech company so you
may wonder how come we've ended up with
this product that the users are
absolutely hate because and it despised
with a passion and the reason is the
electronic health records aren't really
built for doctors they're built for the
hospital administrators most of the
structured data within a hospital right
within your hospital medical record is
going to be structured around billing
what do those people care about well
what doctors did the patients see what
drugs were they given prescribed and you
know we need to keep track of those what
tests were on and who do we bill for
this and how much actually if you think
about this what's actually wrong with
the patient is not one of the things
that they really care about it's it's a
side effect of all of the other things
that you do record but it's not the core
thing that that the systems were meant
to record and as a result you know these
are electronic health records they were
meant for recording information they're
not meant for bringing value back to the
user and doctors as a result CHR EHRs as
a necessary evil and really utilize it
minimally they're there to do their
minimum amount of work to get there to
get to be able to build a patient and
then I'm done so it's so and the second
side of this is that actually doctors
still spent a lot of time on the EHR
even though they tried to do as little
as possible doctors this is in the
ambulatory setting time spent clinic
directly on patient care is about a
quarter of a doctor's time it makes
spend almost about 40 percent on each
our documentation or in review and this
actually 27 percent does not include
the time spent on the EHR system while
with the patient so the EHR is a huge
fraction of what the doctor does and is
really needs to be optimized for their
use so the result of this miss miss
develop technology for doctors is that
what we call patient centric care which
is a big buzzword in the medical space
is that technology is actually over and
underutilized simultaneously and you end
up with cases where the computer for
rather than the patient gets the
doctor's attention and you know yeah and
while the clinical notes are still quite
sporadic and technology is obtrusive it
gets in the way of the doctor-patient
interaction and so it's both there's
both too much technology and it's not
being used so when you'd really better
methods to capture clinical data during
the patient visit and this is I often do
this as a poll when I when they give
this presentation or version of this
presentation in front of doctors I I
think how many of you if you were sort
of left alone completely to your devices
how many would you want to use paper and
how many of you would want to use a
computer and their vote is always almost
always like you inherently like I want
to use paper for my medical records
unless my hospital is forcing me to use
a computer so but they both have
advantages and disadvantages there are
advantages of using paper that's a
familiar workflow you can draw you can
doodle very quickly it's cheap and you
can you know if your paper costs next to
nothing and pens it pretty cheap you can
throw them out if you don't like them at
the same time there are disadvantages to
using paper records there's missing
information there is you need extra time
to then transfer to the EHR system
because at the end of the day you do
need a digital note based on current
regulations and it's a good thing I'm
not saying that's a bad thing
it's inconvenient to take photos or
record the videos if you wanted to you
know capture something in more detail
and it's impossible to compute with
notes you know doctors
writing is as bad as advertised
computers are also have their advantages
it can be faster than handwriting you
know actually you can type even if you
if you're a bad typist you probably type
quite a bit faster than you actually
write by hand it's easier to search not
easy but easier at least on paper it's
more structured and it's easier to share
the identification becomes a bit less of
an issue but there are also significant
disadvantages with using computers there
is missing information there's things
that sell that you didn't put down it
can be slow and distracting when things
don't go right you know doctors are
finding where is the right form for me
to put this piece of data or where in
the medical record did they put this
previously that I can find it later it
impedes patient interaction if you have
a computer screen between you and the
patient really does not work for a good
conversation and even if it's sideways
and some clinicians are amazingly good
at typing and talking over their
shoulder as a patient you still lose
that are they really paying attention
when they're back to their computer
screen and trying to find a piece of
information in the note and it's still
inconvenient to take photos or videos
especially with modern with with desktop
computers which is the mainstay of the
hospitals and really uh when we started
thinking about well what should this
process look like
future of note-taking for doctors we had
to go back to 1945 to see what they
thought would be the right way to for
doctors to take notes and this is a
Vannevar Bush article called as we may
think where he coined something which
you called MMX which is a device that
stores for an individual all of their
memories and all of their interactions
so that which can be consulted with
expedient speed and flexibility so it's
actually interesting what Vannevar Bush
in 1945 thought MMX would look like it
basically was something that looked like
GoPro camera that's mounted on
somebody's head and a tablet that you
can use to draw and
and and pullout and useful and then she
we also be shown information so you know
in 1945 he did not have these things
available to him but in 2019 we're
getting pretty darn close to having
something like that that you can
actually pull off so we started thinking
about what artificial intelligence can
bring to the field of actually not
medical data processing of where there
is a huge area work but actually
clinical note-taking you know things
like handwriting recognition which has
advanced you know huge have made huge
strides recently speech recognition
where we can listen to the audio stream
be talking between the doctor and the
patient and pulling out relevant piece
of text identifying who the speaker is
theorization near natural language
processing to identify what are the key
medical terms that have been mentioned
in the doctor-patient conversation and
actually giving in real-time clinical
decision support to give the doctor some
thoughts about the data that they have
just recorded so all of these have been
brought to build together in a sort of
test tool called keynote add that was
built by Josh one who is interning here
now which is why I'm visiting in part
and to the idea was to build a way of
better way of taking notes and there you
can see this for clinical genetics so
this is just one area of medicine among
you know hundreds depending on how
finely you want to slice it but it's one
of the things that you know we talk
about is why is it so hard to do the
good health or electronic health record
system it's because you have to build it
for all areas of Medicine you know my
research group this certainly does not
have the capacity to do that and what so
what we've been saying is like let's
build something for one group genetics
is good because we have a lot of
interactions with them it's good because
it's very broad it covers all areas of
Medicine but at the same time there is
the appointments are much longer
so in appointment the doctor could be an
hour so it's a lot easier to fill in you
know like there's two minutes for a
technical issue that we have to deal
with or here's a new device that you can
try it'll slow you down by a couple of
minutes
the doctor is much less sensitive to
that than primary care setting where
it's sort of ten minutes next patient
ten minutes next patient ten minutes
next patient so in this system
architecture it's actually built on
surface and that's what I'm using here
to do the demo and I'll be showing you
parts of in the pad life and as well as
we have a HPC system basically our own
cloud where all the speech recognition
happens we also combine it with a local
raspberry pi based computer that is we
used to record video over the encounter
if with patient consent obviously
obviously all of this with patient
consent and it can be controlled from
the surface so that the clinician can
start and stop the video for example on
their surface that they have in front of
them while and same with the audio if
the patient does not want to once the
audio off for a short bit of time that
can be done off of this off of the
device and what we've done this on the
surface because we've really found it to
be the best in terms of the handwriting
recognition and everything that we've
played around with and that you know
it's been a good device to develop so
just a very quick demo I'm going to show
demo just a small part of it live and
then I'll play a video for the speech
parts I'm having some network issues
from here connecting back to our speech
servers in Toronto
but the idea is that it looks like you
know paper it looks like something like
this and and I can just as a you know
start writing and you can see my
handwriting is pretty bad but it's
identified that that scribble that I did
there is the word headache and I can
click on that and it is now added to my
patients record as one of the features
of that my patient presents with and if
I can actually click it again just work
here you can actually set it to be
negative somewhere else I'll show you to
me later and then maybe patient also has
fever see that no it's too bad but
favorite does not come up
there we go so headache and fever it's
one of the things that the system is
doing is if I write something like
kidney cancer you can see that the term
that has popped up at the top is
actually renal neoplasm which is the
standard way a geneticist would talk
about it
kidney cancer is just a standard but
that's the one that sort of been blessed
as the formal name of the term obviously
the same thing and if I write CA
I'll say hey did you mean cardiac arrest
but actually see it could mean multiple
things coronary artery corneal abrasion
calcium or cancer so I can easily you
know select that no actually you know
what I meant cancer and new plasm will
show up and I can delete cardiac arrest
is not really relevant to my patient the
interesting part is if I you know I'll
show it again here far ite you can see
it's thinking cardiac arrest but if I
right
breasts see it's actually recognizes
that the breast cancer that's meant so
it's aware of the context of the text
that I'm actually writing and it can
determine what the abbreviation is most
likely to mean based on based based on
that context it has also other some we
have pretty simple cool features that
clinicians have asked us for for example
can draw a little Square and say I'd
like to take a photo and then and then
can take photo and insert it now this is
not part of my note and I can draw on it
or I can sort a picture in a similar way
or draw a little you know pictogram that
makes it usual so my thought here is
that this is halfway between a computer
and a and the paper and gives you some
of the advantages of both similarly you
can easily swap it all back into text
and then download it as a electronic
medical record into your into your main
EMR system this has many other features
like you can input whole piece of text
and identify and edit the text on the
fly using a pen just by sort of crossing
things out or inserting things and then
saying and then writing out by hand the
little piece of text to go into the
middle of the medical record which I
won't you know show and the other part
that this has is the audio component and
that is not working live so I'm actually
going to switch back and show a little
video part I can show you I can show you
that so if you have an existing medical
record you can cross something out here
at the very top and then either
highlight and then you know write a note
about that you can insert new content
right here so you just click pull it out
write some piece of text and then the
handwriting to text will
take it into into actual and and improve
the note we've used this for clinicians
who wanted to basically preach art and
bring the what they expect the chart to
look like into the exam room with them
and then just quickly update it so that
when they leave the room they actually
have the note Grady
so clinical practices vary quite a bit
between even within a specialty between
individuals so for those who wanted to
preach art we built that note that in so
yeah and the other part is the audio
part and similar to empower MD which you
guys possibly know about or have built
there are components which allow you for
speech analysis you can turn it on right
here so and and then you have a
conversation that conversation goes
through the same text analysis pipeline
and we pull out medical terms and then
you have the ability to confirm them set
them as negatives as relevant to your to
your patient as your as you're doing
this finally the system of clinical
decision support and you know they can
actually show that live so if I go to
right here I can see you can see a
patient has fever and headache it gives
you ideas of what else you may want to
look for and these don't really make
sense because these are all genetics
diagnosis for a patient who has fever
and headache and shows up with that the
genetics clinic not to their you know
primary care doctor so don't worry you
probably do not have cutaneous
hyperthermia with headaches and nausea
that's not very likely unless you've
recently undergone say you know a
surgery and and they had anesthesia and
but this but this gives you a something
else to think about and it's short
differential list which maps back to
omean which is the rare disease they
rare disease main rare disease database
with diseases that match and if
something isn't negative you can for
example click open ID to say no fever
and that'll update your differential or
if you add a couple other features that
will also update your differential and
update other things that you may want to
investigate
so that is to give this technician in
real time so that they can do this while
they're with their patient the
differential process is part of the you
know thinking about clinical decision
support it's super important to get this
done
in real time as the doctors with the
patient you don't want the decision
support once the doctor has left the
patient has gone home yeah so what we
have found is that for the differential
parts you know our differential and our
decision support is much worse than an
experienced clinician at this point so
experience collision gets very little
value out of that but a junior clinician
actually gets quite a bit so the fellows
who are seeing it's like this is the
first time I'm seeing disease X I've
read about it in the textbook but I
don't know about this and this is very
common in the rare disease world this is
for them this is very valuable and it so
it gives them some it does it's not this
enough to be perfect but gives them
thinking points to give them I have I
thought about that disease baby even if
it's wrong but why is it coming up on
the list hey oh it's like those three
symptoms match so it's it's actually as
a training tool it could be very
valuable and kids is a teaching hospital
yeah some of these are obvious you know
but some of them you know you know
docent actally I think have asked the
patient to take their socks off it's
dodo sandesh likes and actly is one of
the two fingers Jordan and fused
together if you have dos and Ecklie you
wouldn't know if you have shoes on so
it's so it's a and do it knowing to do
this as the patient is still in the room
not you know calling back and saying hey
by the way or you have huge toes so so I
think so this is the shows you sort of
the hope can turn off this stuff this
shows you sort of the brief overview of
how fina pad works what I want to do now
is talk a bit more about the machine
learning that has made peanut pad
possible and this is work by a couple of
students somewhat just wants help as
well want to talk about named entity
recognition for ontological concept so
how do we when you know the patient
rights kidney cancer or sorry the
clinician rights kidney cancer how do we
know that they actually meant you know
neoplasm or small head is the same thing
as microcephaly is the clinical term and
this is the work of our A&R Bobby a PhD
student in my group so the goal is to
really take on structure text here with
assume that the speech the text part has
been done and annotated with structured
terms so there is a little paragraph
here you can give you a few seconds to
sort of scan it very briefly to see if
we can no you just finally see there's
quite a few medical terms that are
mentioned in it you know we can
highlight a few of them there's a few
others and then how do we pull pull
these out so the terms that we actually
want to pull out our human phenotype
ontology terms HBO is the rare disease
ontology it's great for genetics for
those of you who are sort of more
familiar with broader medicine you may
have heard about sno-med CT which is the
the whole clinical world HBO is just the
genetics you know types of things you
can see in the genetics clinics so you
won't have broken bones you won't have
like a broken you know fibia you will
have potentially to break bones which is
a genetic phenotype and then you know
which bone you break is sort of depends
on what part you hit and this is hard
work of Peter Robinson the monarch
consortium I always make sure to
acknowledge them because this is a huge
service to the rare disease world so if
you go back on the annotation example
some are pretty easy to pick out so
biliary atresia there's an HBO term
called biliary atresia it's you just
pull it out it's there you know you can
do it with that ctrl-f for our little
grep others are trickier like
craniofacial changes maps to abnormal
facial shape and abnormal facial shape
if you look at HBO it has lots of
synonyms it has things like facial
dismorphism which is I think the
standard term no it's it won something
it's commonly used
it has unusual facial appearance has
funny-looking face and if you're hanging
around doctors enough you will hear you
know them discussing FL keys funny
looking kids but which is certainly not
politically correct but but has doesn't
appear in notes but certainly I have
heard that the I've heard is mentioned
by in casual conversation but abnormal
fascia but craniofacial changes is not
one of those things so how can we
actually identify that from the text so
there are lots of challenges with this
there are 12,000 terms in HBO so if you
think of classic named entity
recognition methods you need 12,000
different classes training data for each
of those classes and that's not going to
scale and so named entity recognition
methods such as Nero's TM CRFs work well
for a few classes less than 10 when you
have training data for those specific
classes and here we have some labeled
data but it's really literally a few
hundred abstracts of medical text that
somebody has gone through and pulled out
hpo labels on the plus-side
medical anthologies have a taxonomy of
concepts so what I did not show you here
is that different phenotypes here like
coloboma and globe of neurons they are
joined them to a structure so if you
know coloboma
and globe abnormality are both close to
each other
semantically and they're all some kind
of an eye issue so and more so I'm
morphology issue so this structure
actually can help enable better and the
indentity recognition so to do this we
start with word embeddings which I'm
probably in this audience don't need to
discuss too much so mappings of words
into high dimensional space so that
similar words are in or near by vectors
and further combine the word embeddings
into phrase embeddings where you know
again pretty standard things you know as
of you know two years ago I needed to
explain this today I don't think you
know most people are would be aware but
basically when we take you know words we
have a convolutional layer max pooling
and the fully connected layer to build
an embedding for a whole phrase
so the phrase cancer of the retina you
can take the underlined word vectors and
combine them into an embedding for the
whole phrase so pretty standard stuff
what we have done though is because we
have not just individual phrase but we
actually have structures among the
phrases we have built a hierarchical
concept embedding where the idea is that
instead of embedding each phrase
completely independently we are
embedding it relative to its relatives
relative to its ancestors so the idea is
that the root term of the hpo is
something called phenotypic abnormality
and that has some embedding possibly 0 0
0 every vector being 0 and that I have
normality is something that's relative
to this so positive vector that adds
something to the vector for phenotypic
abnormality cancer is something that
adds something to there to its parent
which is also genetic abnormality and
then retinal abnormality is something
that adds on top of abnormality retinal
neoplasm on the other hand is something
that adds to both its parents so it's
one of its parents is retinal
abnormality in one of its parents is
cancer so the embedding for the term
retinal neoplasm is going to be the sum
of the what it adds and all of its
parents so it's going to be this because
it combines what's along of both of its
parent tracks and the idea is that this
can help us learn better embeddings with
less data you know we can actually learn
about the fact that retinal neoplasm has
something to do with eyes and has
something to do with cancer even though
those terms don't explicitly occur in
the term retinal neoplasm right because
there's an i parent and there's a cancer
parent and then when we have an actual
phrase we can combine we can compare it
with the encoding that we get from the
concept encoder so we encode the phrase
separately and compare it to where the
different concepts of the hpom code
using this hierarchical structure to
actually get a similarity score
say which of these terms is the most
likely one so that years to bring the
ontology into the machine learning and
this is a sort of a brief visualization
of how much it helps this is the same
exact same algorithm but in one case
we've basically taken out the hierarchy
and said embed everything the exact same
way but without using the using their
each build structure the exact same
terms you can see that without the
structure sort of like it looks like an
impressionist painting the colors sort
of all bleed into each other a little
bit while when you use the hierarchy you
get much tighter clusters for each area
of the ontology this is just the various
systems you can take a look there is
this thing called grey thing that sits
in the middle and here it's what's your
words in here right here so the thing
that sits in all in the middle of all of
this is new plasma because you can have
a neoplasm of any really body part so it
makes sense that from analogical from a
embedding perspective a duck map to the
middle because because of the structure
so we've compared with other methods so
rule based concept recognizer support
for HBO and for other biomedical
ontologies train the only training data
we used was 228 abstract so basically
nothing and with we fused 40 as validate
is a set to test the tuning threshold so
the threshold of how close do you have
to beat something to actually be
reported and the other 188 were used as
testing and also clinical reports from
about 40 undiagnosed disease program
patients these are patients seen at NIH
for an undiagnosed disorder where
clinicians have built notes but also
have recorded hpo terms for every single
patient and so I wouldn't be talking to
you if them our method didn't perform
better than the previous methods you
know the data is not difference is not
huge here's an interesting part though
so the - each is what happens when you
drop the hierarchy and you can see there
is actually a quite significant
difference in f measure if you are if
you
once you if you remove the hierarchy
from from that from the method the
hierarchy helps a lot so bringing in
medical knowledge has really improved
our ability to do named entity
recognition we've also expanded this to
basically say well what what if I don't
get the right exact right term can I get
the directories get a general idea to
get a nearby term and they're what we're
measuring here is to say well let's say
the true patient had these terms
annotated in the ontology but my
annotation reported these two terms it's
probably not fair I didn't get right I
got there's none of them exactly right
but hey you know I got a sibling here
and here I got a parent of this term so
how you know how good did I actually do
so what you can do is measure accuracy
and based on not just the term but
what's based on what's shared including
all of the parent terms HP ontology has
is their property so if something is
selected its parents are also guaranteed
to be true so if you have a collab oma
you have a normality of the eye
morphology and you have abnormality of
the eye and you have some kind of
phenotypic abnormality more broadly so
if you do this numbers go up and again
you can see that the method outperforms
sort of more standard rule based methods
same thing with clinical reports and you
can see here our recall was quite a bit
lower than on them abstracts but we
wanted to know why this is why did we
actually work with or in our precision
as well why are we finding things that
are not in the medical record so we
actually look back for three cases and
did a manual annotation of every false
positive that our method reported there
were 73 of them half actually were
judged by clinician to correct them we
had more information things that should
have been in the medical record should
have been annotated but they were not
added to the HBO list by the clinician
about 8% was something like slightly
more specific like you know we annotated
limb ataxia and the questions just said
ataxia and there was like yeah yeah
ataxia is sufficient you don't really
care if it's limb or not and would not
17% were mentioned as negations so what
the doctor said is the patient does not
have X and our method is completely
unaware of this and this is actually a
huge problem and something that we need
to improve on and about 20% of those
were true false positives things that
really were not present usually
investigations or something like that
so something that was a test or
something that was just a mentioning of
a body part which for the system felt
was abnormality of that body part so
it's the actual system was publicly
available you can download it under a
BSD license and you can play around with
it it's actually used in quite a few
different places besides phenotypes
which I you know pad which I just showed
it's used by the tool called Pino tips
that also was developed in my loop in my
group sorry some you know used by a
paper which is data visualization to
mine the concepts that could then be
visualized and foundation 29 which is a
group that's associated with Microsoft
and such as part of is is using this
text mining tools to mine rare disease
patient medical records the second part
of again of how we can use AI to help
enable the interaction process so I
showed you abbreviation disambiguation
and this is the work of a master student
Martha Martha screechy
so we go from here things like a fib
with our IVR to actually fibrillation
with rapid ventricular response and I
mean the motivation is kind of obvious
you know people want to use
abbreviations there it's fast but
disambiguating is non-trivial so when
you say RT did you mean retrograde
tachycardia radiotherapy or respiratory
therapy and there's a think there's also
write the just word right could be
another example so can we disambiguate
these abbreviations by looking at the
context and previous work has shown that
you can look at not just the local
context but also what other words appear
in their document there's a global
context as another signal it makes total
sense because even though the
words right next to a set word may not
reveal to you the meaning the general
subject of what the note is about can
give you a lot more information so this
is an example like if you had the phrase
patient was treated with RT in 2018 well
what's RT could be radiation therapy
could be respiratory therapy
probably not retrograde tachycardia you
don't get treated with that or not
probably not right and that you can get
from the local context but which of
these two is right well if you look at
the global context of the note can you
see that the other things that were in
note are si forget to me chemotherapy
thoracentesis cancer lung sort of gives
you an idea that radiation therapy is
probably more likely than respiratory
therapy so we do this with again with
you know deep learning combining word
embeddings for the individual words in
the sentence with the more global word
embeddings weighing everything by tf-idf
sort of so rare words gift get the
higher representation combining this
into an abbreviation representation and
doing classification with this network
at first we did this on sort of what
everybody plays with their abbreviation
disambiguation the medical setting with
CAHSEE and mimic so we trained all of
our embeddings on mimic which is a huge
data set of of medical records that are
come out of MIT and then we trained the
actual model to CNN on on CAHSEE using
which has about 500 examples for about
70 abbreviations and the standard
cross-validation train test split and
ran it and hey guess what it did really
well so all methods actually do pretty
darn well even naivebayes get you 94%
accuracy but you know with our best
model which combined the local and the
global setting we're able to get 97%
accuracy and we were very excited by
that and then we sort of said that's
great let's implement this into our
model and and into this into final pad
and very quickly realize
that most abbreviations we did not have
so we have 67 abbreviations and Cassi
for whom we have 500 examples of
training data we looked at all acronyms
which is a website and we actually see
eventually us we got the whole week
download the whole thing it has 80,000
medical abbreviations about 20,000 of
those have multiple possibilities in big
you agents so you really are talking
about a lot more than the 67 for which
we have training data and our first idea
was can we use reverse substitution to
eliminate hand labeling so let's go
through mimic every time we see patient
was given intravenous fluid it was
became the phrase became patient was
given IVF because intravenous fluid maps
to IVF and created the training set in
this manner so within this so this
becomes something with the label of
intravenous fluid it was like okay great
the problem was that the patient the
phrase intravenous fluid appeared in
mimic 2,500 times so enough for us to
get a decent training set another
meaning of IVF could be in vitro
fertilization and the phrase in vitro
fertilization appears in mimic zero
times it actually is interesting the
actual reason for it we initially
thought that just nobody wants to write
out in vitro fertilization it was
actually the reason was different the
reason was that the word vitro was
thought to be a last name so it maybe
has lots of examples of in square
brackets last name fertilization but but
you know still the point still here is
that the in vitro fertilization as the
whole does not appear even once so the
question is how can we generate a
training set given this so to do this
we've actually used multiple other data
sets we still relying on mimic 3 and all
all acronyms we've also brought in you
MLS which is a large ontology of all
medical concepts that we're actually now
going to use to help different
some big u8 the abbreviations and the
actual pipeline works as follows we
train fast X and word embeddings on
mimic on mimic we collect training
samples from mimic using reverse
substitution but then we augment the
training examples using related medical
concepts and finally train the CN n for
the classification task so this is sort
of how this works when you have we take
all your MLS terms and their mimic
clinic notes and you embed the ml you
are my less terms into a high
dimensional space so there you will have
things like realization fertilization
assistant fertilization pregnancy in
vitro fertilization all in one area
while fluids intravenous fluids liquids
fluids and electrolytes these are all
you MLS terms would be in a very
different area of the high dimensional
space so then when it comes time to
figure out what are the sample training
samples for and Eitri fertilization we
take the term India fertilization say
well hey it's really close to assisted
fertilization for which we do have some
samples that we can pull out from the
reverse substitution and because
assisted is not a last name at least
according to a dynamic and there's also
terms like you know toxemia in pregnancy
which is not really related but it would
appear in the same types of nodes so the
global context is going to be quite
similar or fertilization which is again
not as close but again would give you
some or would give you some notes with
the same kind of global context and then
we sample from all of these using
basically soft necks with a temperature
where temperature helps us really hone
in this to how much how deeply we want
to sample from the node itself if there
are any examples verses notes that are
the verses nodes that are further out
for things where there are examples so
intravenous fluids we still do the same
thing so we actually you know have a
fake distance of epsilon to the actual
node itself so that we don't sample from
it completely but then we have all of
the
nodes nearby and again the temperature
basically set the temperature to zero
you will be sampling from there oops
from the node itself completely if you
set the temperature to be really large
you're basically sampling from all of
these nodes with equal probability and
we looked at you know how this performs
relative to the various temperatures
that we could set it's actually
interesting performance and mimic drops
as you decrease temperature because what
really the model is doing it's
overfitting to mimic and the lower your
temperature the more you're actually
getting things from mimic directly as
they are well performance on a
completely orthogonal data set going
back to the 70 examples where we have
ground truth the Cassie examples if she
goes up as the temperature goes up and
then sort of stable you know for
stabilizes and falls back a little bit
so we ended up using Bayesian
optimization with validation loss on
mimic to optimize this but leaving out
their sort of really small numbers
because main liquid that's where it sort
of tends to push them up and you can see
that when you add this relatives the
model that we have built right now it
gives you quite a big push in terms of
accuracy on CAHSEE both in terms of
micro accuracy and Mak your macro
accuracy about eight percent higher than
you get with the exact same model but on
but but not using the relative sampling
just from the nodes themselves and while
interestingly enough performance on
mimic drops because you're in the you
know you're you're no longer overfitting
to the mimic data set you're actually
building something that's much more
generalizable so as a conclusion so
breviary
effectively disambiguated using local
and global context and the prior medical
knowledge can help overcome some of the
biases in our training data but still a
large gap you know remains we were able
to get 97% accuracy by training on
CAHSEE and testing on CAHSEE we're able
to get you know 73 percent accuracy by
not using a CAHSEE at all and any of our
training and not having any hand
labelled instances still a lot of work
to do but hopefully at this
as a way forward the cool part about
this is now we can do all 80,000
radiations better or worse the problem
being we don't know how well we're doing
because we have no gold standard data to
even to test on besides the 70 that
Cassie has provided us so finally I just
want to summarize some of the things
that I've brought up in my talk and I
talked a lot about you know what going
back to the original point AI enabled
note-taking the cool what I'm trying to
do with this work is to really use
technology to assist the patient
interaction to make sure that technology
is a participant in the care of the
patient and not an impediment to the
care of the patient and to do this you
know the goal is to really capture
everything
no speech and eventually video we're
already capturing video a bit but we
don't really know what to do with it and
there are lots of privacy concerns with
capturing video so at this point you
know the but at the same time eventually
you know when you say you know
does it hurt right here and the patient
said yes well unless you had video you
don't really know what what really
happened so I think eventually we may go
there as well you want to generate
recordings that are easy to browse going
back from the not just looking have the
whole speech but actually pull out
information and locate important
information automatically in the future
as you're discussing with a patient as a
clinician is discussing with a patient a
particular indication you may want to
pull out previously relevant reports oh
you're complaining about you know knee
pain
oh let's see I guess yes yeah you had a
you know soccer injury for which you had
surgery on that knee 20 years ago how do
I know that well hey the medical record
should be able to identify any pain like
okay let's find out all of the knee
related notes that I have previously
further for my patient and provide the
clinician clinical decision support on
the fly beyond the differential
diagnosis which is what I showed you for
genetics but you know what is this what
is the right dosage of a medication you
know on the fly I'm going to give you X
given that the patient is it has this
weight and you're
you may think about this dosage as
starting those for this medication kind
of thing and really as we're evolving we
need to start thinking about electronic
health records and we need to start
thinking about electronic health systems
so an electronic health system is an
active participant in the care of the
patient it's there with the doctor and
trying to walk the doctor through what
could be the things that are a problem
and read and then it records the
clinical data non-invasively helps the
clinician navigate previous notes and
tests structured data with computation
in mind and be built with data sharing
in mind which is not something I've
talked about but really the
identification on the fly being able to
share a case with a colleague on the fly
and get a second opinion quickly these
are all things that really need to be
built into the electronic health system
of the future finally I need to
acknowledge the people who did all of
the hard work so dish one led the
development of peena-pod working with a
team of software developers and students
Martis Creta did the abbreviation
disambiguation and had help from other
grad students in my group and ariane did
named entity recognition work and with
folks at nih and machine learning folks
at toronto finally thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
and very happy to take any questions
[Music]
No
so we don't have that right in our we
have we we don't we have the global
context of that to know I guess yeah we
do have that we could combine it over
various notes for a patient I've not
thought about that it's a very cool idea
and because that's obviously would have
a lot of information as well we've just
been doing global context with at the
node level so what are the other words
in the note with the idea thinking that
a cardiology node is going to be very
different than a you know oncology note
you don't have to at least for the just
as a follow-up question to that at least
for the data that you do at your
hospital you don't have to be identified
content of you know I mean for the data
we're dealing with internally no we
don't have to de-identify it but for our
data we don't have we have zero
annotations you know we don't have
anybody who we're paying to go or throw
and look at every radiation and see what
it actually meant so data you don't have
it you can't get one monster to dinner
records because because it's
identifiable wants to fund you to your
interest yes so they changed the patient
ID for every one of them so when you get
that you just talk you don't get
longitudinal data same kind of question
for the clinician but it seems like a
clinician will be doing similar things
in their practice so right now no but
obviously you know when we're when we're
looking at the global context the notes
with other notes written by the same
clinician are going to have very similar
global contacts so it's going to be
taken into account a bit naturally
obviously you know if you the more
information you can build into the model
you know same patients you know same
doctor second visit for the exact same
thing you know that's additional
information that can be used to better
mine the information and better come up
with a note you know on the empower I'm
these are the team side you guys are
generating the note which is not
something that we're doing and they're
it's like well okay take the previous
note and see what has really changed
between the two interactions that you
know could be very powerful but for us
you know for now we're just sort of
we're starting from the top and mmin
it's you know the difficulty with a lot
of this work is not machine learning
it's their human factors it's actually
getting the clinician time and getting
them to use the device you know hey by
the way we'll be waiting by your clinic
door at 8:00 a.m. tomorrow morning to
make sure that you try using this with
all of your patients today otherwise you
know it's something goes wrong and you
know
they just ignore it have you done
usability studies like yeah yeah so
we're in the middle of a usability study
of finger pad where we've used it for
about a dozen encounters where
afterwards we evaluate both the patient
experience and the doctor experience
where I think where we think the patient
experience is actually a very
significant variable as well so it's
given that we have relatively small
numbers and how I can say much it's the
significant but overall the response has
been positive and are you like what are
your key performance indicators on it
like are you looking at face time it's
it's surveys it's basically if we're
doing surveys of the of the patient
after they encounter we're doing with
the doctor we're doing a bit more we're
doing interviews before and after usage
of the tool to understand their workflow
and then to actually evaluate how what
went wrong or what went right for the
for the for the patient is just a survey
do you feel like the doctor paid more
attention to you using this tool than
using a computer and the keyboard where
do you feel like the doctor was
distracted with you know with the stool
things like that we catch them as
they're leaving the room how do we the
question was how do we make sure the
patients actually answer the survey and
and the answer is like you know if
you're there as they're leaving the room
and you use like can you please do this
it'll take you 30 seconds you can get
that you can get pretty decent responses
their response time so their response
rates this one I'm just curious
those are good to compare different for
example mimic versus Cassie but if you
have a system that is taking notes and
for is to be since you're being
directing a lot the doctors enough
what would they expect it's 90 percent
of the number today 198 that's a great
question
they want a hundred but but but you know
and this is where it
you need to work around the accuracy to
some extent so one of the things that I
showed really briefly here is that when
you you know right you know are a and
you can actually click on that and say
well actually no I did not mean that
term I meant something else so if you
make it very easy in the user interface
for them to correct an error at least
our experience has been that they're
receptive to that but obviously there's
going to be some fraction who is going
to throw this out and say you know this
is useless and so the you know and
arancinis approach is that there should
not be user interface and that's and
that's and then no and that's and that's
fair enough it's it's but it's but but
your point is it's quite good quite this
is valid you know it's 90 percent good
enough well if and the feeling is if
it's 90 percent where in the other 10%
you make a deadly error no obviously but
if it's 90 percent where another 10% a
term gets missed in the electronic
health record and really it's still
there as are a just it's the wrong kind
of RA
maybe it's dollar able it really will be
in the case-by-case specific basis yes
yeah I think it's a question happens
once I choose from 10 or 15 things but
then next time the next time I would
wanted to really say yeah it's always
alright or not most the time I do this
right so fight my selection choices go
down to something then is pleasure would
say oh this is actually kind of useful
if it gets right every time if I have to
repeat this exercise every single time
I'll get relief us so we're actually
collecting those Corrections that they
Commission is doing we're not using them
yet but that data is getting collected
in the system oh yeah I mean yes I mean
and then so it's important to get that
data per user and update the system with
these and this is their again like the a
I need to be
part of the UI so along the lines of
personalization are you thinking about
the I have my own abbreviations and I
want to have them be a part of your
system but maybe obviously you don't
want to affect the model because their
person yeah I mean again I think that's
very fair for a commercial product we
would certainly you know that certainly
would be the case I think where we are
at is we're trying to build a something
that we can test in a hospital
environment and you know write paper or
a few papers describing how well it
worked and then potentially work with
you know a bigger partner in terms of
getting it to a commercial in getting
some of the technology that we have
built into a commercial grade system
we're I'm not you know planning that
this be sold you know to compete with
empower and D in the next couple of
years it's it's it's not it's not our
goal at all it's a great question we
just we were just discussing this before
about how you know it's actually great
to take advantage of the behavior of
clinicians who tend to for example
restate everything that's you know I am
we have knee pain also you've knee pain
so basically using the fact that the
clinician is going to restate it if it's
important and get confirmation I think
that it's a good question I've haven't
thought about it but one thing I would
you know say is that pretty much every
single rule of thumb that I've come up
with about how clinicians behave I found
lots of counter examples so you know
talking about behavior change as a whole
it's it's it's difficult I would say
that the rule if I were to pick on
something I would not pick so much on
the clinicians as on administrators who
make it the
really difficult to it's very difficult
to bring new technology into a hospital
even on a trial basis it's for good
reason but still it's that the number of
roadblocks thrown up sometimes valid
sometimes not so much is makes it makes
it makes it really problematic so not so
much collisions like outside of the
hospital environment a lot of the work
is really loved ontological work in the
you know is were really medicine
specific so that's going to be hard to
validate outside of a medical setting
but the same question for testing cause
I'm just wondering can like could this
whole thing be mapped to like I don't
know the dog world or some negative
health was like is er sorry I mean
that's could be an interesting because
they have they have you know yeah some
of the previous tools we built for human
genetics were then actually used by vet
clinics and actually dog breeders who
wanted to track their dogs and like I
had a pedigree drawing tool and they
went to the track which dogs this headed
from which dogs and though the pedigree
of like a thousand dogs and but know
that medicine may be an interesting one
I've actually not explored that that
much but that's that's interesting
thought
that's a good interpretation of what I
said because that's not what I said but
what I really was trying to drive that
is there like a system that has the same
types of like an ontology and different
types of ways that you can do the same
connectivity that you're doing to
develop your mapping in your models but
it has nothing to do with this idea like
customer support as Microsoft actually
has it's very disgusted yesterday alone
like it has very similar a lot of
similarities with with that and trying
to camp troubleshooting all over you
don't have though you don't have the
real world like real-time face-to-face
interaction which is its phone so you
you have audio but but you know they're
like the form factor would be completely
different you know you still have an
ontology you still have feel to the fact
that you have to write this gun typing
would be probably much more efficient I
mean there are there are examples that I
haven't thought about it that much about
I'll think about it and even that
medicine is actually is is not a bad
example but I was wondering like if we
hey you know the surgeons and to draw us
yep John's whoopie pie
oh yeah I mean obviously drawing is
fundamental and that's why you know
compute what that's one of the problems
with computers if you want to now get it
drawing into your electronic health
record that's yeah so you can import an
image and draw on top of the image you
know having and then that's what you
know a lot of them do like they have
these human bodies you know think for
example if you're doing if you're doing
joint diseases you'll you'll have this
drawing where the joints are inflated
and sanely it's like the hands are you
know like basketballs but like that's a
little players hands and then the tiny
tiny body because there's much of those
joints in there and then you can like
highlight which of the joints have
issues things like that and so you
basically can import that picture and
annotate on top of that and this is I
think one of the reasons why I think
that the device that you can actually
work with is valuable and of our bushes
yes that's imply a little bit with the
camera on the surface yeah that's my
question is are your action so we're
recording the encounter with a separate
video already we have permission to put
a head-mounted video on a doctor the
issues we've run into is that the
cameras are too heavy and the batteries
don't last long enough and you know sort
of it's it's they've been technological
issues at the end of the day yes you
want that video but then the other thing
is I don't know the I don't have the
first clue as to how to actually
that data and videos you know if audio
brings up privacy concerns
well videos bring up a lot more privacy
concerns and and and a lot of just
comfort level you know do you really
want to be seen you want to see be seen
by your doctor or cyborg you know right
because that's how you know you will
feel if suddenly somebody walks in with
with that thing on their head and so
it's it's it's it's certainly something
that we've thought about but not
something we've actually we figured out
how to act upon in grant proposals I do
put you know a doctor with it where they
go for on them but but we haven't we
haven't turned one of those loose on the
kids in the hospital you know III don't
know I'm not I'm not like I'm not a
video video analysis person so you know
I don't know how much you can tell by
their from the experience of the video
but then if there if the hand is
obscuring then the doctor won't be able
to see themselves potentially I mean
they know where the hand is on the other
hand but maybe you can use adjacent
markers to figure it out but I think the
video analysis part of still is is still
very much sci-fi it's you know if this
audio analysis part is you know if you
talk to a doctor if you still talk to
most doctors today they'll say their
voice voice analysis part of sci-fi but
it's it's actually getting their the
video analysis part I think that this
the you know the technologists will
think bit sci-fi at least my mind my
view
[Applause]